buongiorno a tutti sì crowd funding
facendo business angel
sono inciampato in questo fenomeno nel
2012 una delle startup investito ha
usato il crowdfunding per lanciare un
prodotto un gioco fisico su kickstarter
mettendo come obiettivo 5.000 dollari in
30 giorni ha raccolto 324 mila dollari
ha detto aspetta un momento cosa è
successo due mesi dopo che ha fatto un
altro progetto obiettivo di raccolta
20.000 dollari questa volta preparandolo
un po meglio eccetera raccolti 728 mila
dollari forse c'è qualcosa da studiare
ma cominciando studiarlo incominciato a
guardare
guardando il fenomeno ho capito cosa non
era altro fanning nel senso che il
crowdfunding non è una forma di
richiesta di soldi per
elemosina cause sociali superiori e
basta
bensì è una forma dove si richiedono
soli per un fine per realizzare un
progetto è tipicamente con un qualcosa
in cambio ai soggetti che vicino a dare
questi soldi c'è un processo
collaborativo fatto dalla gente che
decide di dare i propri denari per far
sì che venga realizzato un progetto da
altre persone che ci mettono la faccia
la credibilità personale per fare questo
questo genere di cose e nella famiglia
dei fenomeni del crowdsourcing cioè di
quel fenomeno che a partire da una serie
di persone permette di realizzare certi
progetti obiettivi ci sono diverse
formule di crowdfunding si parla di
donation bay scrofani ma in realtà è il
classico fundraising dove in pratica ci
sono persone che danno una donazione
perché succede qualcosa di superiore un
progetto che ha una motivazione
più alta si parla di re world campania
per cui in realtà si hanno delle
donazioni in realtà sono dei preordini
dove c'è qualcuno che decide di pagare
prima per avere un ruolo ad un qualcosa
in cambio dopo un prodotto un servizio
quello che si sa si parla di crowd
famiglie ending quando si parla di
prestiti io do dei soldi a qualcuno che
in cambio mi ridà o soltanto i miei
soldi i soldi più un tasso di interesse
secondo sono tante motivazioni sociali o
anche un obiettivo di ritorno economico
si parla di revenue sharing per cui una
forma dove io do dei soldi in cambio un
ritorno in funzione del progetto quindi
o del un ritorno economico dal progetto
che se ne interessi sul prestito che ho
dato formale del genere e si parla di
crowd fanny equity ed equity crowd fanny
e in italia abbastanza famoso perché
l'italia è stato il primo paese aveva
una normativa specifica dove le persone
diventano soci essenzialmente
dell'azienda che fa questo questo
progetto di crowd funding e in forte
crescita
92 per cento di crescita del 2014 in
pratica si sono arrivate 10 miliardi di
dollari di raccolta delle cose fanning e
il 2014 stato interessante ma comunque
negli ultimi cinque anni stata una festa
e mille per cento si vede che la curva
di crescita sta andando verso quella
curva esponenziale che tanto conosciamo
in tanti fenomeni di boom in realtà ci
sono altre domande che possiamo farci ok
un progestinico lo fanno un progetto
complesso tipicamente ci si mette del
tempo prepararlo e delle risorse si
dedicano tempo e risorse energie a rete
un offre invece nel positivo cioè
e tempo le risorse che dedico fanno sì
che dopo in realtà viene ripagato
correttamente questo mio tempo in media
si vogliono 135 ore per strutturare un
progetto di cofani correttamente c'è 45
giorni la raccolta media in un progetto
di carfagni relazione al tempo impiegato
fa sì che in media le ogni ora venga
remunerato 813 dollari per cui si
potrebbe dire che non è male come
remunerazione rava in realtà si bisogna
sempre pensare che si dà in cambio un
qualcosa non ricordo un prodotto un
servizio che ha un costo naturalmente
altro concetto faccio progetto di co
fanning bene ma non poi la mia società
al mio mio progetto provoca a un
incremento delle vendite successivo
progetto per farmi cioè il di là del
progetto di cloud fanese in media i
progetti di cloud fan award based anno
al di là delle resine del progetto
affanni una crescita del 24 per cento
per ogni trimestre nell'anno successivo
al progetto a quando è stato realizzato
con successo progetto di crowdfunding in
media le società ti fanno pacifica falli
equity bass quindi dove trovano dei soci
che diventano soci all'interno
dell'iniziativa hanno una crescita media
per premessa del 35 per cento per cui si
hanno un ritorno positivo anche nelle
vendite successive progetto
bene tutto questo crea un impatto nel
mondo del lavoro siamo in italia dove
questo è un tema sentito in media il 39
per cento delle aziende che conduce una
carica fama e successo assume in media
29 impiegati in seguito al crollo
fanning e un'addizionale 48 per cento
delle aziende che hanno fatto progetti
successo ha l'obiettivo di assumere
nuove persone in seguito all'attività di
cropani per quel che fanno diventano
abilitante naturalmente a al fatto che
l'azienda venne di più anche per questo
cresca sia in termini di fatturato sia
in termini di posti di lavoro creati
alto concetto visto che questa azienda
cresce in realtà poi attira interesse da
parte di investitori il 28 per cento
delle aziende che produce un
un progetto di cofani e successo nei tre
mesi trovo un round investimento da
parte di investitori istituzionali per
cui business angelo venture capital
l'ulteriore 43 per cento non lo riesce a
fare nei tre mesi ma interesse da parte
del sito istituzionale per fare un run
di finanziamento per cui 71 per cento
delle aziende che fa un progetto di
cross selling attira interesse da parte
di investitori per cui se una startup
vuole attirare the party venditori uno
dei modi più efficienti effettivamente
fare un progetto di crowdfunding
in realtà tutti ci concentriamo sul
denaro perché la cosa più evidente più
incredibile per qualcuno ma davvero ci
sono dei soggetti che danno dei soldi
prima verde ira e ward che vengono dati
magari sei otto mesi dopo per diventare
soci di una nuova iniziativa si questo è
vero ma in realtà ci sono tutta un'altra
serie di benefici che il crop famiglia
cioè in un qualche modo da conoscenza
esperienza di un settore di una tv di un
mercato che dove c'è una conoscenza
specifica che si riesce ad avere
inseguito a progetto di crowdfunding in
realtà da una serie d
di
informazioni in relazione alla strategia
utilizzare per approcciare questo
mercato ma qual è lo poteva nel mercato
da appoggiare a come fare il prodotto
cioè i singoli soggetti che mi danno i
soldi per realizzare ogni prodotto mi
dicono anche lo voglio più così lo
voglio più cosa la voglia di questo
colore loro cioè o delle indicazioni da
quelli che sono i miei non è un'analisi
di mercato sono soggetti che hanno messo
i loro soldi per avere mio prodotto n
mesi prima per cui sono i soggetti
migliorini possono dire come vogliono
questo mi ha prodotto naturalmente
un'indicazione di qual è la dimensione
della domanda di mercato e anche dove
geograficamente distribuita se faccio un
progetto di crowdfunding su scala
internazionale che posso capire che
mangia numero di persone che mi
comprarmi un prodotto sta in qualche
nazione che in altre nazioni e posso
anche avere una dimensionalità di quanto
sono disposti a spendere quanto in ogni
nazione e poi naturalmente sì il denaro
è una componente ci mancherebbe ma più
la componente abilitante al fatto di
tutte le altre mi vengono date
si basa tutto sulla fiducia che io
riesco a creare nei confronti di
soggetti terzi cioè se una promessa che
io faccia dei soggetti terzi
dipende da quanto io sono credibile fare
questa promessa quindi è più probabile
che riescano a farlo dei soggetti che
hanno questa fiducia pregressa cercando
una credibilità in sé e mettermi in
gioco tra virgolette questa credibilità
fanno progetti di cross selling che poi
devono rispettare nei termini di
consegna nei termini economici se mi
hanno dato per avere un prodotto
servizio poi devo pagare quel prodotto
servizio in cambio di quel tot queste
persone mi hanno dato questo concetto di
fiducia e centrale questo concetto di
fiducia fa anche sì che è sia molto più
facile per chi ha fiducia maggiore nei
confronti del suo letto dei soggetti a
condurre con successo un progetto di
crowdfunding se uno non ha questa
fiducia pregressa è difficile che riesca
a fare un progetto dic la spagna è
successo si dice che il primo 30 40 per
cento dei fondi che vengono legati in un
progetto di co affanni vengono date da
femmine in france da soggetti che mi
conoscono già e usano lo strumento per
aiutarmi a far partire mio progetto
nell'equilibrio della startup che in un
qualche modo cerca denaro e che bendetto
quindi può attirare mese dominante che
la fanno in dove si colloca al cloud
vanni ita miraworld ben si colloca molto
all'inizio dove ho una prova del mercato
riesco a far capire a
dei soggetti anche terzi che esiste
questo mercato potenziale che io ho
identificato
tra famiglie qui ti based si coglie un
po più avanti dove ho avuto questa prova
di mancato posso pensare di raccogliere
anche soldi da una serie di soggetti che
sono diventati magari miei fan anche del
campanile world based che diventano soci
della struttura della società e quindi
riesca a raccogliere denaro per fare
iniziare l'azienda dopo nella fase di
evoluzione l'azienda c'è il mondo del
venture capital e poi dei mezzi
istituzionali quali parlate equity e
quant'altro quindi come strumento per
l'investitore ok ma dal lato
investimento come il rapporto rischio
rendimento regionali quando si diventa
soci della società
i prestiti bancari hanno un rapporto del
suo elemento della cliente basso gli
investimenti da parte di ben giorno di
venture capital business angel è il
rapporto di rendimento è il più alto
diciamo che l'equity che orfani si
colloca più o meno in mezzo ci sono
varie formule che sono nate di
crowdfunding e verticalità che vengono
utilizzate se vitro fanny è uno
strumento tipicamente di innovazione
sociale cioè dove la folla di cittadini
decide insieme di o partecipare e quindi
mettere soldi proprio perché succeda un
progetto di utilità civica oppure anche
soltanto di indirizzare soldi della
comunità
la comunità
di parigi a 4 ha avuto 4 mila cittadini
che hanno destinato che hanno decidono e
deciso come destinare 20 milioni di euro
e tra quindici progetti quindi 4mila
cittadini sono stati interrogati per
capire come allocare denaro pubblico su
progetti e la francia sta studiando per
il 2020 del locale il 5 per cento
dell'investimento pubblico a progetti
dove il dove indirizzare i soldi è stato
deciso dai dai cittadini
altro fenomeno che viene che chi è nato
è entrato anni al servizio del live
science della ricerca scientifica la
ricerca scientifica tipicamente questo
polemica essere lontano dal
dell'interesse collettivo
viene utilizzato il kraut farmi
tipicamente per ricollegare la ricerca
all'interesse collettivo per cui quello
che viene fatto in pet a forma di equity
crowdfunding odio le uova piano fan e
quindi quello dove si diventa social
award è quella dove in cambio si sa
qualcosa
in realtà ci sono dei progetti di
ricerca scientifica che vengono
postati che vengono sottoposti
all'attenzione della comunità ci sono
tipicamente del peer review cioè delle
revisioni da parte di altri ricercatori
che dicono la bontà dei singoli progetti
quindi io sono competenti dico che
questa cosa qua è buona se lo dico
soltanto io magari non vale niente ma se
lo dicono cento come magari quel
progetto a questa credibilità e allora
le persone poi decina di finanziare un
progetto un alto i progetti di crowd fan
nelle livescience di successo
tipicamente abilitano poi ventures avete
da investire ci sono già tante società
che hanno fatto il progetto di
crowdfunding award bass nel mondo della
ricerca o ai fini della ricerca e dopo
hanno avuto il venture capital che ci ha
investito in seguito per chi ha visto
che effettivamente la comunità di
soggetti ha ritenuto quel progetto
meritevole interessante eccetera quindi
siamo di fronte forza nuovo paradigma
nel mondo della ricerca scientifica che
è sempre tanto bistrattata nel
nei nei fondi pubblici
ci sono correlazioni che queste cose
quale hanno capito meglio l'olanda che
un paese con 8 milioni di abitanti per
cui è relativamente pochi in confronto
anche soltanto a a un'italia che ha
avuto la prima piattaforma di cefali qui
ti based nata si chiama simili che oggi
addirittura quotata over the counter
quindi in un mercato regolamentato
avuto dei fenomeni di civic fan di un
ponte sulla strada su una superstrada
della città di rotterdam dove le persone
hanno destinato auto soldi per
finanziare il ponte ognuno in cambio ha
avuto il suo nome su un asse sul ponte è
diventato un fenomeno mondiale perché è
il finanziamento è stato di qualche
milione di euro oppure un giornale un
giornalismo il giornale che dava
l'obiettivo di fare giornalismo
d'inchiesta dei giornalisti hanno detto
vogliamo fare un giornale indipendente
fare giornalismo l'inchiesta non essere
sottoposti a nessun
servilismo nei confronti di nessun
potere forte però abbiamo bisogno di
soldi per mettere in piedi giornale
hanno raccolto 1,3 milioni di dollari in
tre abbonamenti per un giornale in gulan
dese era uno dei fenomeni che è stato
presentato all
al film
al festival internazionale del
giornalismo di perugia dello scorso anno
che tra l'altro anche sullo stesso fece
internazionale stato fatto grazie al
cloud fanning quindi uno strumento che
in alcuni paesi stai venendo utilizzato
strumentalmente a fare dei progetti
anche le utilità sociale i casi sono i
più disparati
il fenomeno più finanziato su
kickstarter istat è la prima piattaforma
al mondo come entità di soldi raccolti
da quando in atto raccolto ad oggi 1,6
miliardi di dollari tre progetti
strutturate sull'istante il progetto che
ad oggi è quello che avrà quanto più
soldi a breve ce ne saranno altre che
raccoglieranno di più in realtà perché
ce ne sono alcuni che sono ancora tra
milano che stanno raccogliendo di più ma
in questo momento è un progetto
finanziato e cura coolest un frigo da
campeggio con dentro
una memoria per ascoltare musica del
motore per farci frullati mentre siete
in campeggio eccetera
la prima volta che è stato presentato in
famiglia non ha presentato in inverno
con l'obiettivo di 125.000 dollari e non
solo reciterà 425.000 dollari
al che il soggetto che aveva su trovato
il progetto la ripensato ha fatto
correttamente un piano di marketing
un progetto che aveva più sottoposto a
quattordici case produttrici perché lo
facessero e tutte 14 hanno detto non se
non se ne parla non ci crediamo in
questo progetto
lui l'ha riproposta otto mesi dopo
l'estate strutturando meglio il progetto
ed è lecito raccogliere 13 2 milioni di
dollari quando aveva messo l'obiettivo
di 50.000 dollari e 325 milioni non ce
l'ho fatta allora ne voglio 50.000
cinquantamila in realtà hanno fatto sì
che la gente abbia raccolto 13 che abbia
finanziato con 13,2 milioni di dollari
avendo in cambio il frigorifero
portatile da campeggio anche cose
leggermente improbabili nell'opinione
comune se guardiamo cosa è successo nel
progetto vediamo che quando il progetto
ha superato il secondo progetto di
maggior successo come entità di somma
raccolta ha avuto ancora una impennata
esponenziale perché la gente ha avuto
questo questo modo di anch'io voglio far
parte del progetto di successo
oppure esplode in kittens un
mazzo un gioco carte da 20 dollari dove
fatto divertente poi con i gattini che
esplodono che uno dice ma no ma un gioco
con i reatini che con ok raccolto 8,7
milioni di dollari da 220 milioni di
persone in 30 giorni quindi i fenomeni
ci sono fenomeni mondiali
gli americani fanno sempre cose strane
sì ma anche da noi succedono cose una
società di torino ha messo in piedi un
progetto di crowdfunding per una giacca
di cotone idrorepellente bella
particolare naturale ha raccolto 40 mila
sterline di prevendita da 250 persone
oppure una casa editrice sempre di
torino che fa
tarocchi e la seconda terza casa edifici
al mondo per la stampa di tarocchi ha
fatto le enciclopedie reti rocchi ea il
primo libro delle enciclopedie la messa
in chrome fanny raccolto 30 mila
stradine di prevendite del libro del
primo libro dell'enciclopedia di
tracking rod fanni in trenta giovani
finito un mese fabio meno cui si può
fare non è che non si può fare si può
fare ed è un nuovo ecosistema che e
natura e quindi c'è la disponibilità di
nuove professioni anche nell'ecosistema
perché chi è che oggi sa fare un
progetto di cropani successo
quindi cosa abbiamo imparato abbiamo
imparato che è più importante la folla
rispetto al fanning quindi più cloud con
rispetto a fanning perché da una serie
di benefici che sono le cerchi di
mercato marketing supporto locale ci
sono tutta una serie di benefici date da
queste persone oltre ai soli soldi che
vengono dati
abbiamo imparato anche che è una
trasformazione bis mode dove questi fan
questi soggetti questi investitori
diventano loro stessi pro attori del
progetto diventano co creatori perché in
qualche modo dicono la loro e spingono
al fatto che il prodotto il servizio
vengono realizzati in un certo modo e
magari diventano anche loro stessi
proprietari dell'azienda quindi nuovi
modelli polet a una democratizzazione
della finanza
grazie mille